تعليقا على الصوره التي جمعته بالرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي امس في قطر على
هامشي افتتاح كاس العالم قبل الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان المصافحه في
ملعب البيت لم تكون اجتماعا بين زعيمي
البلدين واضاف ان تركيا تنتظر تاسيسا
للسلام مع مصر والعمل سويا في مواجهه من
يتخذ موقفا ضد البلدين في مساله البحر
المتوسط على حد تعبيره كما قال رئيس تركيا
ان بلاده ترغب في نقل اتصالات تركيا ومصر
الى نقطه افضل لفتح طريقي امام لقائه
رفيعه المستوى مشيرا الى ان العلاقات التي
ربطت الشعب بين تركيا والمصري في الماضي
مهمه جدا بالنسبه لبلاده في المقابل قال
المتحدث باسم رئاسه الجمهوريه المصريه انه
جرى خلال مصافحه الرئيسين المصري والتركي
في الدوحه التاكيد المتبادل على عنق
الروابط التاريخيه بين البلدين والشعبين
واضاف انه توافقه على ان تكون المصافحه
بدايه لتطوير العلاقات الثنائيه بين
البلدين